behind me on the dj table is one of the
most prolific
producers that hip hop has ever
presented the mighty mad lib
ladies and gentlemen make some noise for
hip-hop history
[Applause]
[Music]
why did you want to tackle the dude
attempt attempt this is an attempted
attempt i gotta say your tackles are
pretty trash if someone's not even
really seeing you coming and you run in
for a clothesline and
what dave is in his 50s
that's that's a spear but yeah whatever
dave is in his 50s something like that
you can't knock them shut up but they
they've been working out shout out to
dave that was some good reflex so they
published the name of the guy the guy's
name is isaiah lee
decided to do a little bit of research
on this dude
and uh he's a rapper uh he's got some
music up on youtube under the name no
name or yeah something like that trash i
went on his instagram there was no
political posts or anything like that he
had like his top 20
rappers list so there's nothing that
seems to make it look political i think
everybody assumed due to the recent
comments yeah
everybody jumped too yeah it must have
been that could have been somebody who's
unstable could have been an inspired
person chasing clout now a lot of folks
looked at this and had some different
takes i think one detail that was really
important that they caught
was that the man had weapons on them
yeah a knife and a gun i believe yes
replica gun absorbs and um
well if you pull out that [ __ ] i think
it's a real gun you can do pretty much i
mean the knife is uh i think at close
range after attacking someone the knife
is way away a knife isn't yeah um
nothing happened everybody joked
afterwards we're all grateful
had the man pulled out the knife and
then started stabbing him i think we'd
be having a very different conversation
today so it's just something to be
mindful of just because the outcome was
good doesn't mean what happened wasn't
extremely dangerous
and so that's that's just something to
think about but you know what
shout outs to you for what because you
called it
because you said that we're about to see
more of that you said that you you said
exactly that number months ago you said
we're gonna see more and more of this
[ __ ] agreed i just i'm not
i'm not entirely sure what i'm looking
at who nobody is we don't even know what
the [ __ ] that was and why
you try to look for clues
what provoked this you know at the end
of the show whether it be ti
and how he was yelling after heckling a
woman he got mad at what she said
or will getting mad and then storming
the stage and we've seen a few of these
incidents where people get upset about
something like
i think
we've convinced society that what they
feel is more important than anything and
so if you feel hurt or you feel bothered
by something then you get to do whatever
the [ __ ] you want yeah and that's just
wild to me maybe also because of social
media this stuff is more
apparent but i just didn't remember
growing up hearing about stuff like this
not in that sense not in that form you
know
it's not really comparable
i'm talking about people running up on
us yeah they're writing up on a stage i
mean it would happen back then but we
just didn't hear about it like you said
social media right
but
yeah so publicly to public figures we we
no i don't believe it i don't know what
it was people don't
people feel that they're not allowed to
be offended is it that or was it was the
dude really offended or was it difficult
but was it because he was offended who
yeah he attacked him he attacked him so
obviously you didn't have good will
i've seen fans jump up on stage and they
go in for a hug so they just was not a
hug
but that's my point it's like what i
remember growing up was not folks
getting attacked on stage what i
remember is people fans storming the
stage to have a moment or a picture or
like hug their celebrities that's what i
remember
i don't remember this stuff michael
jackson never got appeared
never got spear to be fair
music concerts are different because
they have a whole ass barrier before the
between the front stage [ __ ]
still storm out the stage they try to
hug michael yeah they try to kiss
michael they never try to spear michael
you know what i mean that's one thing
but recently even a rock concert you see
people trying to there's a whole bunch
of rappers that that got knocked off
their feet
at concert and then after that the guy
gets handled recently
so yeah we didn't see that back then as
much or we didn't hear about it whatever
what not but yeah no we didn't we didn't
see that back then absolutely i don't
know to me i'm just watching this stuff
unfold and i think you're seeing the
deterioration of uh
of a lot of the civil liberties that we
got to enjoy in regards to um
you know like listen i might not like
what you have to say but i'ma defend
your right to say you get what i'm
saying yeah it's like there's plenty of
people who i think are important who say
things that are absolutely vile mm-hmm
okay
i couldn't imagine just going out of my
way to attack them because they said
some [ __ ] like that you know what i'm
saying mm-hmm
so
i see this and everyone's laughing we
all got some jokes even chris rock got
his own little joke in where he had a
good laugh about it he's like hey was
that you will right and so
shout outs to everybody to be able to
have fun and laugh about it and i think
that's great but
the man
this could have easily been a tragedy
everybody be singing a different tune
and they'd be crying and there'd be
memorials and all this other stuff so um
to me that's just what i think about
because if he if you ran at him with his
knife dave would be done straight up
most likely so you already know dave's
now his security is going to be beefed
up like crazy because
people saw easily this guy went from
like front row to jump up on stage
somebody who really hates david means
what means like bad things
that could escalate oh yeah real quickly
for the next few months don't try to get
a picture or a autograph from dave
you might get stumped depending on how
you do it that was a nice throwback
though when they showed the footage of
the dude getting stumped
backstage i was like damn i miss hip-hop
i miss hip-hop
hey hey hey anybody getting a shot of
their tim's
anybody going to shout out their teams
i mean you ain't security you got tips
[ __ ] i ain't never scared [ __ ]
i ain't never scared oh
yeah
that's what it was listen they tore his
arm out and glue it backward look at
this
look at his face
oh you got stump all right yeah that's
some swelling boy
that's some swelling boy and some cuts
oh yeah he got stumped yay and he going
to jail too
they got him on assault with a deadly
weapon so he gonna do some hard jail
time but what do you think about the
whole thing i don't know like you you
you embodied what i think right now when
you said that back then uh
i don't i'm not sure what i'm watching
right now
i
i don't know
because nothing explains this you
understand what i'm saying you could go
back you cannot understand at the end of
the show really you could tell yourself
and if he was like really going to
arm
chappelle or
the lgbtq whatever you're gonna buy a
whole ticket
it's a lot to unfold i mean
i hope there's gonna be like whatever
inquiries and stuff like that to know
who this person is and what his intent
is and eventually he's gonna be able to
talk we'll know in a few days but
like you said i don't even know what the
hell i'm watching i can't pin on nobody
nobody
is it wilson's secret society is it
is it the lg i don't know i don't know i
know someone did something and it didn't
bad for him ralph i saw one of the
dumbest tweets
well of course
i said something like
why do we even need comedians anymore
i get more laughs on twitter
from my grandma's jokes than i do
watching any comedians then don't go to
comedy shows that's it then maybe you
don't need it why do we need musicians
anymore because you don't listen to
music i listen to music so why would we
get rid of them i feel like they make
music that's bad for the culture anybody
can make that argument because
undoubtedly music spreads a lot of bad
messages you want to go down that road
like
what you guys are advocating for is the
death of art in general
stupid that's why this political
correctness is bad from both sides
let [ __ ] say what they want to
say
yeah but but then there's consequences
okay well then why does that only have
to stick with words what about thoughts
do you want to get started [ __ ] over
for thoughts what about your social
media posts people getting stomped out
for that
basically you guys want a lawless
society
to me
folks cheering this on or saying this is
good i'm like
what is it that you're fighting
[ __ ] you next
like what do you think do you think it
just stops at a comedian's joke then it
stop that next it's your opinions yeah
because guess what right we got this
whole roe v wade stuff going on with
abortion and all this stuff there's two
sides of it well guess what one side
says you're killing kids the other side
says you're taking away women's rights
they could easily escalate into violence
at any point
if you think some comedian can't get
away with what's saying that [ __ ] you
can't even get away with having an
opinion
that's where we're going this
it doesn't happen from a legal
standpoint it becomes from a more of a
societal standpoint where we
dis-incentivize people from from
from having whatever opinion they want
to have or believing in what they want
to believe in
freedoms
that kind of terror is real
so i don't know to me it's like i've
seen it in comedy already over the last
couple years where comedians are
terrified of saying certain things
they're terrified because they've been
banned some people have been back for
that yeah absolutely
well i know it's not just comedians i
know professors who don't even want to
teach certain things because they're
afraid of what's going to happen
politicians who feel they're compelled
to say this is all snowballing and
comedians we're standing scene at the
last bastion being able to say whatever
they [ __ ] they want yo
every day you're watching this pcniss
make sure everybody's toeing the line
so we have to make an effort as a whole
society to fight back against that [ __ ]
and say no listen i don't like what a
lot of [ __ ] say but they should
be able to say because i want to be able
to say what i want to say
i want to be able to think what i want
to think i want to be able to keep my
job and believe in whatever religion i
want or whatever [ __ ] up idea i want
like yeah
but so long as we create the society
where we incentivize these people to be
like listen they hurt your feelings go
ahead
i don't know
to me i just i think it's just a bad
direction to go in so that's that much
it's weird yeah
what a time to be alive
yeah
i mean this pandemic ended but weirdness
hasn't stopped oh no no i think it
increased it increased it so i think
it's only going to get worse at this
point it's not going to get better yeah
we're waiting for a while
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
a joke
is that a dave chappelle diss track
i don't know if it's a diss track i
don't know what the [ __ ] this mom say
other than it's like lefty you think
it's a joke that's the only line i heard
uh but that's this guy he has a track
named dave chappelle from 2020. okay
okay he's my it's mental illness
all right
well that solves this well i'll tell you
tell us what you think yeah this could
be clout chasing this might be like his
thing of account i don't know what is
going on this this is but judging by the
quality that's this is crazy eyes yeah
this is a little this is crazy guys oh
okay
it's okay
okay yeah it's just
crazy eyes yeah so you got stumped
because you went on stage and you
charged a man and [ __ ] stumped
you
case closed you want an attention you're
not going to get the attention you want
and if it you're going to get it you're
going to get crazy it literally you're
going to get it for
the wrong reasons now
your arm backward you stomped out and
you're going to go in jail
because there's nothing that can
say that
you have a knife and a gun
and you decided to storm and spear him
for what
i don't know
but you're gonna go in you're gonna go
in there
okay
well
sometimes
things happen and we look for a reason
you know when they say everything
happens for a reason sometimes [ __ ] just
happen
[ __ ]
just happened
but you don't think that he got that
idea from seeing other people swim this
state no i don't you don't think he saw
what happened with will smith and then
thought this my time it's a possibility
i'm just saying i ain't there's been i
mean i can't go right for a long time i
can't remember them okay so also let's
say this let's see this
let's say this
it takes a lot to buy a ticket go all
the way to the show bring some weapons
and then set that whole thing up that's
also crazy we have to also be careful to
not always stigmatize mental health and
say that's the reason why people do bad
things
that's also all responsibility
we couldn't assume he was on an activist
tip we can't assume
that he was on a mental health tip sure
i understand which i'm just saying but
mental health is the reason why some
people do some crazy stuff sometimes we
don't know and sometimes people just do
some crazy stuff now
that being said we don't know but oh
okay what think about this
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you